[Musique]
marie laforêt donc on ne donne pas votre
âge en revanche ce que vous voulez que
l'on dise c'est que vous avez était
divorcé plusieurs fois ils n'ont pas
marié ta pourquoi vous tenez ces
différences non je trouve ça plus
amusant mais enfin bon si on doit
s'étaler dessus bon alors j'étais mariée
divorcée voilà dans une carrière de
comédienne et une carrière de chanteuse
déjà j'aimerais savoir ce que vous
c'était un site et un vrai désir de
devenir comédienne et chanteuse
non c'était accidentel ça m'est arrivé
paris se met à river accidentellement
c'est à dire qu'au départ il y avait un
concours de théâtre qui était organisé
par une radio ne prendra de dire par une
station de radio et j'avais un gros
problème qui était que je n'arrivais pas
à parler en public
gt gt bloqué et je me suis dit voilà une
bonne occasion
en acceptant de passer une audition
était même pas question de faire le
concours ben si les 3000 personnes
c'est une histoire de vous juste de
passer une audition si j'arrivais à dire
seulement un mot à raymond rouleau
j'ai l'impression que je serai serai
guéri d'une certaine façon
donc j'ai fait ce concours et puis il
m'a dit vous êtes sélectionné aussi
cauchemar parce que sous steam il va
falloir que je fasse sur scène c'était
c'était complètement impossible
et puis ça a été possible la presse et
que les faits puis voilà puis j'ai fini
par gagner ce concours de théâtre ce qui
était une histoire de fou ça n'avait ni
queue ni tête j'avais pas du tout envie
de faire ce métier
mais alors qu'on comme s'était juste
part des filles comme ça que c'était par
des filles c'était aussi pour pour
essayer de me soigner quoi essayer
d'arriver à projeter hors de moi un mot
en public et en plus de ça c'est à dire
que quand je suis allé voir mon père
donc c'était j'étais bien mineure
j'étais bien obligé d'aller le voir pour
lui dire qu'on avait proposé un contrat
de quatre ans au cinéma et je me suis
dit là le choix entre me passer par la
fenêtre me met le couteau de cuisine en
travers de la gorge
enfin j'ai imaginé les solutions les
plus raisonnables qui me paraissaient
évidente et puis au lieu de ça il a
tapoté un peu comme ça le canapé il m'a
dit mon p'tit vieux tu vois dans
l'industrie quand j'arrive à faire
bouffer mais ouvriers pendant quatre ans
moi je prends le travail
moi je serais toi je prendrai le truc en
fait durée d'activité il a rajouté autre
chose il a dit je m'en excuse carré
blanc il a dit avec le cul que tu as ce
serait quand même dommage mais non il
n'a pas l'air mon cul c'est ma soeur et
ma mère qui les avait moi caudal je n'ai
jamais entendu parler connais tes
petites pourquoi perçoit votre alors à
lui s'est avéré oui maman que les vôtres
ddd des choses des choses inouïes et
nous on fait des choses inouïes quant à
moi j'avais les yeux caca d'oie de la
famille bongo m'a paru plus donc tout de
suite vous avez commencé à tomber sur le
poêle
j'ai pas eu le temps de dire ouf je
regarde pas mais mais je dois dire que
j'aurais fait n'importe quel travail en
fait je suis amoureuse du travail plus
que du meti en tant que tel bien que je
la dore que je sache le faire dauphin de
plus on apprend ce métier plus on aime
le faire plus on aime le faire plus on
la prend donc cette c'est effectivement
un engrenage qui fait qu'aujourd'hui je
suis enchanté de le faire mais j'aurais
fait n'importe qui c'est content mais
absolument pas votre image de quoi ça
l'envi de travail et de mettre les on
voit plutôt comme une image moins malin
et très exactement c'est votre image
oui ben oui ils match que vous avez
proche mais je crois qu'on projette
toujours le contraire de ce qu'on est
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment de
vous être épanoui ne mettrai pas puisque
vous parlez de votre timidité maladive
au départ je sais de gecip toujours
aussi tu es aussi maladivement timide
mais je suis très gai alors ça ça
compense
quand on vous voit vous avez plutôt un
visage plutôt année georges non mais
plutôt triste
a priori alors vous êtes quelqu'un plein
de gaieté et vous êtes plein de
paradoxes comme ça ou est-ce que c'est
l'apparence voilà mais je sais pas je ne
sais pas à quoi ça tient j'en sais rien
vous si je sais à quoi ça tient mais ça
c'est une autre émission aaa et enfin
jure me rangerai l'âme au jeu est
toujours fini nation vous aimeriez la
différente de ce que vous êtes
harry physiquement oui physiquement oui
comment ça s'était laissée là s'exprimer
enfin physiquement cpc pas le feu on ne
voit pas son physique on ouvre on voit
ce qu'on ressent de soi à l'intérieur je
suis pas quelqu'un de je suis quelqu'un
de très de créer inquiet de très fragile
quelque part bon alors forcément quand
je me vois je me dis pas ou [ __ ] la
belle nana je ne peux pas ça me vient
pas j'essaye je fais en sorte je la
maquille jeu l'arrangent
je l'habille j'allumais des costumes va
c'est la poupée barbie à moi je moi je
me trouve plutôt moche hein on veut dire
tu as été absolument superbe je suis
encore ilan on attend n'ont jamais
cherché à bombay où j'ai connu marie a
fait pas 25 ou 30 ans quand tu tournée
leur amérique entre autres on peut avoir
23 ou 24 ans c'est absolument super g
était très secrètement amoureux d'elle
pendant - non tu as encore très bien
voilà eh bien bon gars merci pour la
soirée ce titre c'est pas mal de faveur
on est tous attaqués par l'ag un moment
donné oui non ça je dois dire très
sincèrement que je m'en contrefous
je m'en contrefous pourquoi vous pouvez
vous mettez ça son discours sur le
compte de l'âge oui non pas du tout à
son discours au contraire mari a
toujours été grave elle toujours et
érable c'est pas une fille joue à zhuhai
euse ah bah on n'a pas de s'être enfin
mais cela dit je ne suis pas malheureuse
je mange je m'en accommode très bien de
marie laforêt elle et elle est toujours
là elle elle m'amuse devant eux un seul
élu cheval me fait vivre en bons non je
m'entends bien avec elle maintenant
au début je me demandais mais en 75 vous
avez tout arrêter oui pourquoi vous avez
tout arrêter en 75 pour vous occuper
cette de cette galerie là c'était un
problème différent c'est à dire que
j'avais trois enfants et que la vie de
paris je voulais pas que mes enfants
grandissent à paris je voulais qu'ils
aient je voulais qu'ils aient une une
vie de campagn'art tout en faisant de
bonnes études mais pour ça il fallait
que j'ai un métier qui me permettent
d'être un peu fonctionnarisé c'est à
dire avoir un métier où je commence à 9
heures le matin je m'arrête à 6 heures
le soir
après on rentre à la maison je repasse
là je fais la cuisine on discute on
regarde les devoirs
bon il y avait tout un tout un travail à
faire et c'était cette période des douze
ans 14 en 6 ans 8 ans tout ça c'était il
fallait commencer à s'en occuper
sérieusement la galerie vous l'avez
choisi j'imagine pas pour des raisons
précises
c'est à dire que c'est vrai qu'un
artiste c'est fait pour ces faits pour
apprécier les choses donc que ce soit la
danse que ce soit la musique ce soit la
peinture que ce soit la sculpture la
littérature un artiste c'est une plaque
sensible
[Musique]